it's been six weeks since the tragic
murder of nine-year-old Olivia and today
we have arrived at a significant stage
in the investigation
the investigation team
with support from officers and staff
from across the UK have worked
relentlessly since the murder on the
22nd of August
it has been a complex inquiry which has
been supported throughout by Olivia's
mom and dad and The Wider merseyside
community
I'd like to take the opportunity to
recognize the dedication and
professionalism of everyone who's been
involved and in particular the senior
investigating officer detective
superintendent Mark Baker and the crown
prosecution service in bringing the
investigation to this point I will now
hand over to Maria
the crime prosecution service has
authorized merseyside police to charge
Thomas Cashman 34 from Grenadier Drive
West Darby with the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell
also the attempted murder of Joseph knee
and Cheryl Corbell on the 22nd of August
2022
Cashman additionally has been charged
with two counts of possession of a
firearm with intent to endanger life
I have further authorized the police to
charge Paul Russell 40 from snowberry
Road West Darby with assisting an
offender
I on behalf of CPS Mercy Cheshire have
authorized the charges following a
review of a file of evidence received
from merseyside police
the defendant's first court appearance
will take place at Liverpool magistrates
on Monday the 3rd of October
our thoughts are with Olivia Pratt
corbell's Family at this time
the crime prosecution service reminds
all concerned that criminal proceedings
against the defendants are now active
and that they have a right to a fair
trial
it is extremely important that there
should be no reporting commentary or
sharing of information online which
could in any way Prejudice these
proceedings
and I'll now hand over to Mark camim
who'll say a few words
thank you
as Maria has just outlined today we have
charged an individual with the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia
if I could remind everybody
but this is still very much a live
investigation and therefore our work
involved in it continues in earnest
at the beginning of the investigation we
were affirming our commitment to finding
all of those involved in this case
this includes the people who have tried
to shield and protect individuals and
those who displayed the weapons and
indeed those who are hiding the weapons
used in this attack
I therefore still need people to come
forward and speak to us
we have had an overwhelming response and
levels of support from the public since
the tragic murder of Olivia
I want to ask for that continued support
so that we can keep the promise we made
to Olivia's family and the local
community to ensure that those involved
face Justice
anyone with information is asked a
direct message at merpol CC
or contact Crime Stoppers anonymously
at Crime Stoppers UK or telephone them
on oh 800 55511
again if you have any CCTV
dash cam or smart doorbell footage that
could help our inquiries they can be
uploaded on the dedicated public portal
for Olivia's murder and that will go
straight through to the investigation
team
footage can be submitted at the public
portal
map.police dot UK
finally our thoughts today are with
Olivia's mum and dad Cheryl and John and
their families who throughout the last
few weeks have shown Incredible strength
courage and dignity
thank you